not many remember the name of Mary
Mallon if not for tragic circumstances a
strange immunity and her position at the
center of an outbreak of disease it's
likely that she would have faded into
obscurity as just another ordinary
immigrants who gave up her homelands for
the promise of America in the mid 1880s
Mallon was just a teenager when she left
Ireland and headed west landing in New
York City in 1883 or 1884 she had
connections there at least an aunt and
uncle that she lived with until she
found her feet if that was all there was
to the story history wouldn't remember
her she would have been one of the
millions of Irish you emigrated to the
u.s. in the 19th century a time when an
estimated 50% of the country's
population picked up roots to try and
make a better life elsewhere but Mallon
was carrying a deadly disease with her
and it marked her as typhoid mary but
there's more to her story than just a
gory nickname and remembering her as
just a carrier of disease doesn't quite
do her credit
[Music]
[Applause]
since typhoid fever is one of those
old-timey diseases that isn't really
talked about in the modern
industrialized world this conversation
deserves a short for word on what
exactly the disease is it's caused by
the bacteria Salmonella typhi and most
of the time it's passed from one person
to the next through food or water that's
been contaminated in some cases being in
close contact with someone that's
infected can spread the disease as well
symptoms can take up to a week to
develop and they're generally rather
unpleasant the infected have to contend
with a wide range of disease markers
including fatigue muscle aches abdominal
pains swelling and sweating ranging all
the way up to other things like fever
and extreme gastrointestinal distress
without treatment the disease can
progress to delirium and the so called
typhoid state laying they're too
exhausted to move with your eyes half
open it's at this stage when other
complications can develop some might
start suffering from hallucinations and
paranoid psychosis while others might
develop inflammation of the heart
pancreas or brain the most serious
complication is intestinal bleeding
which in some cases can lead to holes in
the intestines typhoid is treatable
today but even modern vaccinations are
not 100% effective the exact course of
the disease was confirmed in 1880 after
years of attempts to document exactly
how contained instances of the disease
could turn into epidemics typhoid had
about a 10% fatality rate at the turn of
the 20th century and the first vaccine
it wasn't developed until 1911 that's
five years after Mary Mallon was hired
to cook for a well-to-do New York banker
named Charles Henry Warren and his
family
[Music]
not much is known about Malins early
life in Ireland's or her first years in
the United States she was born in County
Tyrone one at the poorest areas of
Northern Ireland on September the 23rd
1869 and she left her home Nan's for the
US when she was only 14 or 15 years old
there was nothing unusual about her
in fact she followed the normal route of
settling in with family members who had
made the crossing before her then
finding work as a domestic servants
things started to change in 1900 when
one of our employers discovered that she
was a talented cook they put her to work
in the kitchens and it was a move that
changed her life and the lives of those
who employed her Mallon works for 8
families in the years between 1900 and
1907 and wherever she went
typhoid fever often followed at the time
typhoid was an illness associated with
crowded and poor urban communities with
non-existent sanitation and little
access to fresh drinking water
Milan however was working for some of
the most affluent families in the city
which were not exactly the sort of
families that tended to suffer from
afflictions like typhoid doctors did
notice that they were unusual victims
but remained baffled by the outbreak of
illness in homes where there seemed to
be no logical explanation for it
Mallon Spears became sick at seven of
the eight jobs that she held in those
years at least 22 individuals fell ill
and at least one died there's nothing
that indicates Mallon initially had any
idea the illnesses were connected to her
in any way and she continued to cook for
various families because she did move
around a bit and because she never left
a forwarding address it took a while
before anyone could connect the dots in
the summer of 1906 Mallon was hard to be
a summer cook for Charles Henry Warren
and his family they'd rented a house on
Long Island and in August one of his
daughters took ill it was of course
typhoid and it wasn't long before her
sister mother a gardener and two maids
were also sick the owner of the house
was George Thompson and he was
understandably worried no one would want
to vacation there if it gained a
reputation as a place where an entire
family could mysteriously fall ill they
were afraid the area water source was
contaminated and knew that they had to
find out exactly what happened before
they could rent the property again
Thompson looked for and found a
professional to get to the bottom of
he hired New York City Department of
Health sanitary engineer George Soper to
find the source of the infection and he
knew exactly what to look for as he had
specialized in the study of typhoid
outbreaks a first Soper thought that the
freshwater clams that had been served to
the family were a likely source but not
everyone who developed typhoid had eaten
them eventually though he honed in on
Mallon as another potential source of
the disease his theory was quickly
confirmed Mallon moved on from the
Warren family and showed up next as a
cook in a home on Manhattan's Park
Avenue Zant's we're sober followed her
and that's when we meet her
[Music]
in order to confirm
Mary Mallon was indeed a carrier of
typhoid so perd knew that he needed to
have her body fluids tested for presence
of the bacteria it's kind of hard to
imagine just how awkward that
conversation had to be when Soper
introduced himself to her and asked her
to provide samples he stated I was as
diplomatic as possible but I had to say
I suspected her of making people sick
ins that I wanted specimens of her urine
feces and blood it did not take very
long to react to this suggestion she
seized a carving fork and advanced in my
direction I passed rapidly down the long
narrow hall through the tall iron gate
and so to the sidewalk I felt rather
lucky to escape now with the benefit of
hindsight it's easy to vilify Mellon we
know that she was a carrier of typhoid
but she almost certainly did not
she had never developed the disease
herself and she did at one point
voluntarily subject herself to testing
for the bacteria the chemist who
performs the test who was a respected
professional declared that she was free
of any sign of the disease it suspected
the tests were performed when she was in
a period of remission which certainly
didn't make things any easier on either
her or Soper I mean you could just
imagine it imagine a stranger appears
out of nowhere and accuses you of being
responsible for spreading disease and
sickness everywhere you worked
you are allegedly responsible for deaths
just by the fact that you feel fine and
have never been sick at one point a
doctor had even told you that you're
completely fine it's no wonder that
Mallon was less than willing to submit
to more tests amid rumors that would put
her entire livelihood on the line there
is another element at work here too and
that may have attributed to Malins
violent outbursts when she was
confronted the late 18-hundreds was a
time when the Irish were emigrating to
the u.s. in droves fleeing oppression
and starvation in their homeland some
made the journey on so called coffin
ships packed with desperate immigrants
and so filled with disease and death
that an estimated 25% died before they
completed their journey their bodies
just ended up at the bottom of the
Atlantic those that did reach America's
shores were starving and destitute by
the time they got there and there were a
lot of them anti Irish and anti-catholic
sentiment it was strong and while there
were some groups that offered charity to
the refuge
there were more who whispered of a
secret plot orchestrated by the Vatican
to instill Catholicism in America as the
dominant religion the Irish they were
condemned for supposedly taking jobs
from Americans and gallivanting as
drunken criminals politicians who
rallied about the Irish nuisance were
preaching all elderly from their pulpits
do a public that was more than happy to
listen homes and churches were burnt and
mob violence took lives it was only in
the 1880s that some politicians began to
see the large number of Irish as
valuable allies but signs of no Irish
need apply were still fresh in
everyone's memory for Mallon it very
well could have felt that this was just
one more way for her new home persecutor
for the accents that she kept for her
entire life still Soper knew he was
right and he couldn't walk away
he discovered exactly what it was that
Mallon had served to get everyone sick
ice cream with fresh peaches heat may
have destroyed the bacteria in other
foods but the uncooked peaches and
melons unwashed hands were the perfect
way for the disease to spread in 1906
there were 3467 reported cases of
typhoid and 639 of them were deadly the
actual number of cases was probably much
higher and if typhoid mary was spreading
it everywhere she went it was only a
matter of time before the city had a
potential outbreak on its hands at the
time so who was familiar with the idea
that people infected with disease could
pass bacteria on to others through
various bodily fluids but since Mallon
wasn't sick and had never been this was
completely different from anything had
seen before by the time Soper caught up
there was a new job in Manhattan there
were already instances of typhoid in the
household that she was cooking for one
servant was infected and the family's
only daughter was dying so he followed
her to the boardinghouse where she was
living and again he confronted her with
no more luck than the last time after he
was turned down for fluid donations for
a second time
Soper requested help from the New York
City Health Department
he gave them a warning and that was that
they might need to use force the health
department's gave her one more chance to
peacefully agree to submit to testing
and sent dr. s Josephine Baker to see
her when she still refused to cooperate
they sent the police Mallon tried to
flee but was eventually found forced
into an ambulance and taken to the
Willard Parker Hospital in what dr.
Baker described as a wild ride one where
dr. Baker was forced to sit on her the
entire way to help restrain her she
wrote it was like being in a cage with
an angry lion and it was no wonder she
struggled police had carried her into
the ambulance after a five-hour chase
and Mallon was convinced that she had
done nothing wrong once Mallon was
transferred to the care of a hospital
her bodily fluids were tested repeatedly
three times a week from March to
November for traces of the bacteria that
causes typhoid most of the tests
confirms the typhoid bacteria was there
but there were still some tests that
came back negative which explains why
she might have had a clean test prior to
Soper's intervention it wasn't long
before Pope himself found himself
sympathizing with Mallon she hadn't
infected people on purpose but she was
still dangerous and now she was being
held in a small uncomfortable hospital
room under lock and key you are she
herself was perfectly sound of mind and
body he tried talking to her tried to
get her to cooperate even suggesting
that she could have her gallbladder
removed as it was a non-essential organ
that was probably the source of the
infection but she refused to talk to him
she stayed in custody for a full two
years before she sued for her release
Melon are using court that she never had
been sick but the courts have you'd the
findings of the medical research far
more compelling and refused to release
that that was they said largely because
they didn't want to bear any
responsibility should anyone else get
sick or died from contact with that it
was another 11 months before Nylund made
a deal with the health department she
could go free as long as she checked in
with them every three months and never
cooked or handled food for others again
Mallon agreed was released and promptly
disappeared and well here's where things
get a little bit dicey Mallon did spend
some time working in other professions
and she did get jobs in places like
laundry is where she would have been no
danger but she found it almost
impossible to support herself and the
temptation to return to cooking which
paid a lot more was too high so she went
back to the kitchen where she continued
to cook and continued to in fact a lot
of people at this point
Soper was officially off the case but he
continued to keep an eye on her she
popped up cooking under the pseudonyms
mrs. Brown and Mary brush off finding
where I can
fancy hotel and a sanatorium both in New
Jersey along with a hotel in Southampton
and restaurants on Broadway it's
impossible to tell just how many cases
Mallon caused burst it was a lot it was
during this period that the press had
officially christened her typhoid mary
but here's the thing there's no real
evidence that suggests Mallon ever truly
believed that she was the cause of all
these instances of typhoid fever at the
time that she was first arrested and
diagnosed she was the very first example
of a completely asymptomatic patients
there was ever studied if the medical
community didn't understand the
mechanics of what was going on or how
was Mallon supposed to it's also
suggested that there was another massive
oversight in Malins case when she was
released she was told not to cook and to
take extra care when it came to hygiene
but she was never given any sort of
specific instruction on how to properly
disinfect herself and keep the bacteria
off her hands and while she was never
given any kind of retraining or
direction on other ways that she could
support herself there was no welfare
system or aid available Mallon assumed
authorities were simply trying to label
her a scapegoat for the outbreaks and
she didn't seem to think that she was
actually doing any harm when she
returned to cooking Mallon was initially
released in 1910 and it wasn't until
five years later that a man named dr.
Edward B Cragen approached Soper he was
the obstetrician at the Sloan Hospital
for women a facility that had recently
had more than 20 people fall ill due to
typhoid he had a suspect and a sample of
her handwriting and asked Soper if he
could identified their cook he could and
it was Mallon sober advised him to reach
out to the health department and he did
Mallon was arrested and was sent to
quarantine on North Brother Island an
island in the East River that was home
to a hospital and a quarantine facility
built in 1885 it was home to patients
suffering from illnesses like
tuberculosis small pox yellow fever and
of course typhoid Mallon would live
among them until her death in 1938
instead of feeling relief so he painted
a heartbreaking picture of a woman who
no longer fought against her own
confinements he wrote she had been
advertised to the world as a dangerous
person and had been treated worse than a
criminal and yet she had not been guilty
of the least violence to
anybody allen seemed resigned to a lot
in life finally admitting to herself
that there was a wave of typhoid that
swept along behind her wherever she went
she was not the same person when she was
apprehended the second time and there
was little left of what Soper described
as her almost pathological anger she
settles into her confinement willingly
enough and they gave her a job in the
laboratory where she ran medical tests
they even gave her permission to visit
the mainland where she regularly headed
into the city she always came back if
she seems resigned to her later
confinements it was a resignation she
hadn't felt in her younger years most of
what we know of Mallon is through the
writings of Soper and other medical
professionals although there are a few
of her letters that have survived in one
she describes being so distraught over
being arrested and confined to a
hospital for the first time that she
develops an eye twitch that led to the
paralysis of one eye the condition which
went untreated when she was given
medication she complains that she didn't
need it it was mainly used to treat
kidney issues and she didn't suffer from
any kidney issues she wrote of doctors
that told her she needed to have her
gallbladder removed that admitted to her
that the surgery might not make a
difference at all she wrote I'm a little
afraid of the people I've been in fact a
peepshow for everybody even the interns
had come to see me and to ask about the
facts already known to the whole wide
world the tuberculosis men would say
there she is the kidnapped woman dr.
Park had me illustrated in Chicago I
wonder how the said dr. William Park
would like to be insulted and put in the
journal and call him or his wife typhoid
William Park and it brings up an
important question did Mallon deserve to
be vilified to such an extreme extent
should she have been advertised as
cracking skulls into a frying pan as at
least one illustration showed her doing
or was she just simply a victim of
typhoid in her own way
[Music]
Mary Mallon was credited with directly
spreading typhoid to at least 50 people
and three of them died she's even been
named as the patient zero who likely
started a typhoid outbreak in 1907 one
that ultimately escalated to around
3,000 cases even though she's one of the
most infamous when it comes to healthy
people who have the potential to spread
a deadly disease she was far from the
only one by the time she died more than
400 others have been identified in New
York alone in fact somewhere between 1
and 6 percent of those infected with the
type of Salmonella that causes typhoid
become healthy carriers and it's a huge
problem that the medical world hasn't
known much about until very recently it
wasn't until 2013 that studies done by
Stanford University School of Medicine
researcher Deniz mark yielded some
insight into demonstrating the
mechanisms by which bacteria might
infect a person without making them ill
figuring out the mechanics of just how
it all works could lead to the
developments of the treatment that would
block typhoid --za bility to hitch a
ride in a seemingly healthy host just as
it did to Mallon today there are a lot
like her out there typhoid impacts
around 60 million people a year across
the globe and even on the low end that's
a hundred and sixty thousand people
capable of spreading infection just like
Mallon did
Soper wrote about her death after he was
fairly certain he had tracked down her
sister though he could never
conclusively prove their relation on
Christmas morning in 1932 she was
discovered on the floor of her cottage
paralyzed from a stroke she was moved to
the hospital where she lived until a
death on November the 11th 1938
afterwards there were advertisements
taken out in several newspapers for the
span of a month appealing for relatives
to come forward to claim that list of
money that she left behind no one ever
did only nine people attended her
funeral and no one followed her to
witness her burial instant Raymond's
cemetery in the Bronx
there's a bit of a rumor surrounding her
death as well an autopsy was said to
have turned up a high concentration of
bacteria in her gallbladder and this of
course leads people to wonder whether
she would have been cured if she'd had
that removed however some researchers
including Soper say there never was an
autopsy and that the tale is just retold
their way to help justify our
imprisonments and rather this is true
well it's impossible to say so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below and do not forget to
subscribe brand new videos Monday
through Thursday also when you're
subscribing hit that notification bell
so you actually find out where we put
out a new video and please do check out
our sister channel called Geographics
this channel is about people that
channel is about places I'm going to
link to it below and as always thank you
for watching
you